[music playing]
NARRATOR: There are
far deadlier creatures
lurking in the undergrowth,
as I discovered when
I was out looking for firewood.
This tree right here
is a perfect one.
See this bark?
It's like paper, and it just
peels off just like that.
The bark of this birch tree
is waterproof and flammable,
which means it'll
burn, even in the rain.
[suspenseful music playing]
Whoa.
Look at that.
[suspenseful music playing]
I did not even see that there.
Look at the colors
on it, and look
at how it matches this lichen.
It's so well camouflaged.
But this beautiful snake
is also a deadly one.
[suspenseful music playing]
They have infrared sensing pits.
It's a kind of sense that humans
don't have, but pit vipers do.
This stealth predator
can detect its prey even
in complete darkness, and
it's armed to the teeth.
Look at those
things right there.
They have hinging, venomous,
hypodermic needles.
And those hypodermic
needles, those fangs,
are hooked up to venom sacs
in the back of its head.
And that venom is likely to
be some of the most powerful
in the world.
I need to be
incredibly cautious.
This snake is certainly
capable of delivering
an extremely venomous bite,
one that could even kill me.
It's kind of twisting up here.
I'm starting to push my
luck, so I'm going to release
it carefully and retreat.
[suspenseful music playing]